yeah welcome to this video i'm playing
castle lay here from the netherlands
international master played him before
but i don't remember any of the games
gather slightly offbeat line I am what
really wasn't even aware that this is a
play will move this line i am exhibit in
my repertoire series really if I just
play Queen d5 how do you protect the
pawn why not just winning this
yeah but i can i can even play f 6 cm f6
wait wait wait wait
should I i have this III idea take and
III rook g1 yeah this looks like proper
nonsense
you can also just take him after which
she may be has queen age five okay let's
just take that and continue to develop
this position is is awful for white
anyway I mean the structure is just the
catastrophe
yeah I'm not quite sure how he defends
e6 cannot really believe that f5 is a
booth so we'll just do six let's let
slow deaths Castle here must be must be
good relief now Bishop Bishop to h6
should be nice just attacking the pawn
here
yeah she's just collapsing on d to get
taking on only four was really a strange
move
ki or should I first and it lets you
capture first why not it's got no way to
defend it to anyway
okay so yeah just take it you should be
should be ok so night a4 may be taking
be too
you
I really hoped that Queen takes be too
would be made I didn't calculate but
when I come on this planet cannot change
otherwise check so how to meet the snow
a five yeah a five yeah threatened
screen a to mate and could be four made
so I don't think his is able to defend
that so rook be one that screen a to
mate check this isn't made us wrong
check checkmate don't see that too often
came on a seven um yeah we cannot simply
this is just just a complete lemon
cannot do that may be here he needs to
play deform may deform I can play deform
awk we need to or something the real
lemon is f4 sorry which can be punished
in various ways but this is quite quite
good I think only only this one I don't
know if if I would take here check now
this is not so convincing you don't want
to exchange the Quincy I with the white
Sun King position being completely
wrecked so I think how I played it was
quite okay this keeps an enormous
pressure on and ce4 ID 16 really oh ok
thanks for watching